nous on n'est pas des bêtes et on a des
enfants aussi c'est le contrat que je
reçoive aujourd'hui un message pour me
confirmer la distribution des denrées
alimentaires alors que j'aime m'y
attendais même pas un soulagement du
côté des bénéficiaires l'antenne de
trappes continue ses actions auprès de
100 familles ce jour line demi douzaine
de bénévoles s'est rassemblée pour
distribuer des sourires malgré les
masques et un autre engagement pour
certains non non moi je trouve surtout
des vacances des enfants et les familles
mais là dans l'urgence il faut des bras
donc il faut donner un coup de main
parce que malgré la crise les gens
continuent de manger les gens qui sont
difficultés sont doublement difficulté
mais les équipes ont dû s'adapter mise
en place de règles strictes des lignes
au sol à ne pas dépasser et de nouvelles
techniques de distribution
ici les bénévoles sont passés au drive
on a effectivement fait décoller plus
gros parce qu'on n'est pas sûr d'être en
capacité d'avoir assez de bénévoles pour
maintenir les distributions parce que
beaucoup des bénévoles sont des
personnes âgées et à risque et donc
confinées chez elles
l'ensemble des bénévoles portent des
masques des gants et on a dû y aller
droit alcoolique à disposition avec des
de l'eau de javel de l'alcool ménagé
pour pouvoir vraiment tenté au mieux
d'éradiquer ce virus et des
distributions qui continue dans les
yvelines comme ici à saint cyr l'école
le secours populaire des yvelines
réfléchit aussi à apporter un
accompagnement scolaire par téléphone ou
visioconférence